[Music]
how are you greeted by cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
spanish the bucks
nevares initiative program caused a 32
percent increase in vaccinations around the
state the organizers of this raffle
say that the privacy of each winner
is protected  but they alert the
community about scams and false calls
the health organizers say that the
participants do not have to pay any
fee to be part of winning a prize
nor do they ask for
personal information or bank account
and residents of the valley return to the
streets for the third  Consecutive day to
protect and protest in a show of support
for the Cuban people Several protesters
gathered on the set in Las Vegas and in
the surrounding area to demand an
end to the communist regime established
for 62 years,
protesters say that relatives and
friends who live in  the island does not have
to eat
or medicines this is the first time
in decades that  e the cuban people go out to
demonstrate against the dictatorship
people around the country show their
support and ask the us
government to help them
and the singer usher is back in
las vegas with his residency starting
on friday inside the scales site coliseum
He will be performing during
the months of July and August, also in
December and January 2022 tickets
are already on sale and we finally pass
with the temperatures Friday will be a
hot day reaching 108 degrees
remember to stay hydrated and don't
forget to protect the protector  solar
rain is also expected for the
weekend that will last until the middle
of next week I am Cristian
Cásseres with his brief
news now in Spanish good day
[Music]